good morning Millennials and welcome
back to the toast happy Tuesday Jax how
you doing
I'm doing good
ish goodish go go okay so here's my
situation I don't have a ton of clothes
here right now and so I'm kind of like
cycled through everything I've worn it
like once on the toes so I asked Claudia
to bring me some sweaters today so I
came in like leggings and a tank with
like these cute sandals and she brought
me The Cardigans that she owns Which is
so sweet of her it's so sweet and so
generous and what have you done since
receiving my Cardigans trashed them
because they're so ugly and it's not
your fault
I brought you the clothes off my back
yeah literally you now own all of my
Cardigans yeah I must it's probably not
that hard for you to part with them
because they're they're so stunning I
love them all you're a [__] like I hate
how I look today so that's why I'm not
great because I hate how I look even
though I got a blood and a haircut
yesterday I was so excited to be on the
toes and I just have nothing to wear I
can't wait for the comments to roll and
be like Jackie obsessed that's better
Link Link Link Link Link
the sweater Jacks okay turdy where's the
sweater from I will be shocked if anyone
says that enormist I brought on the toes
and I got so many messages
so many yeah
really it's hurtful like my God
schlepped all these Cardigans here just
to be yelled at and made fun of I'm not
upset with you I'm
upset with my situation
ever and like you get to look so great
well I bought a new outfit and I'm
excited about it well I bought a new
outfit too and literally we had the
exact same morning because I put on my
boy set loudly too boy Sly set they had
a big sale last week and I just looked
like a [__] blimp
but your hour blimp
so I couldn't walk out of the house like
that Jackie what happened to no negative
self-talk
what happened to reality
such a good rebuttal what about reality
but in reality you actually look right
today so stop okay thanks like I like
the sweater your hair looks great you've
got you know a nice flush to your skin
leave it alone thank you leave it alone
okay I just
if you're looking at me being like what
the [__] is she wearing that's still not
her I just want to say like
it's trying times and I've been ordering
so many maternity clothes and doing well
but some things like I got a lot of
athletes you're not right for them so
some things that would show leg not
right for the toes here's the thing it's
like you can order as many clothes as
you want they'll last you a week like
new clothes
are like fleeting it's like there's so
many days in the week yeah
and if anybody ever actually like went
through the last couple of months of
like what I wear on the toast they would
see like six items I literally wear the
same six things but like I shake them up
every week yeah what do people do so I I
need to get to that place right now I
have like three good things okay we'll
keep building when I have a new sweater
you're welcome now I have this gorgeous
and I also give to Jackie the period
sweater that I always wear that she
loves I hate
and I figured it was time you know the
passing of the torch not only did I only
want Cardigans like I don't want
something to put over my head that's
just like blimp season
uh it's horizontal stripes oof it's a
beautiful sweater with meaning in
history and it's ugly colors it has
meaning I have no place in May it has it
has meaning it has history and it's got
family it's a family heirloom at this
point I just think you're trying to
sabotage me like you show up looking
like that and then you bring me this
sweater
it's like day two which is like kind of
starting the show
attacking no not attention because it's
not coming from me tension requires two
sort of tense parties this is just an
attack attack your aggressive act came
in the form of this sweater
okay okay should I put my button down
back on that I wore over here you look
great stop okay
what if Harry heard his mom talking like
this about herself the woman he loves he
would say yeah
I'm really I'm being I'm becoming hurt I
am becoming her hi you didn't make you
didn't crochet it I might as well have
and how do you know that I didn't you
didn't even ask where it's from it's
Zara I can read the label you didn't
even ask
I didn't ask I need to ask even though I
could see it I crocheted that sweater
with my to my fingers bled
it's made with so much love is that what
the hearts are
I will not participate in this mock in
this charade
no no I'm not sorry thank you you should
be no no I'm fine the wrong salutation
I'll take you and I I'll take the sorry
I know you was an instinct but I'll take
it I'll take it a reflex we've got a
great show today how about you anything
to say in my direction oh yeah you're
welcome
um we've got a great show today lots to
discuss girly swirlies just being girls
and twirlies
and 30s and charities
shirties
shirt tees shirties
um so yeah that's like what's up with me
oh I started anyone's book last night
and I'm about halfway through his books
are just like so easy to read it's
basically a diary where he Diaries his
life every day I I find it really
interesting but I also was thinking like
there's so much about his book that's
like very in the know in terms of like
Bravo in terms of New York and just in
terms of like entertainment industry
that I feel like if you're not really
into either of those things like why
would you pick up the book but like it
might be confusing you know like what
well first of all he refers to like
every Bravo Liberty just by their first
name and it's like well they do
every day he documents the book and then
he's like finish the show watch up
inside weed Craig and Paige said well
what if you don't want a summer house
you know what I mean like yeah it's a
little in the know and then he's also
just talking about like
there was also some interesting things
he'd be saying how he had a meeting with
Casey and Danielle from the [__] sash
podcast and they pitched him an idea to
like package their old podcast episodes
for radio Andy content so it's just like
interesting like business stuff but like
does everyone care about that you know
that's interesting to me but yeah I
don't know that that's interesting to
everyone what happened with it never
followed up I don't think it ended up
panning out interesting yeah but he is
really close with Casey and Danielle he
had dinner with them like one of the
nights he goes out to dinner every he
puts a kid down and goes to dinner I'm
like how much energy do you have I guess
he does work at night too so like having
dinner before is like not what time does
he wake up oh literally you get you
would actually find the book interesting
it's really like a working dad because
he like documents every day when the
kids wake up it's like sometimes it's 4
30 and most of the time it's like 6 45
yeah
um but I that's what another takeaway
for my book The Man doesn't sleep
but he does nap every day when the kids
are napping oh that's nice and also as
you get older you just require less
sleep yeah but he works mornings radio
Andy and nights
watch weapons live if successful people
just don't sleep like that's kind of a
prerequisite to being successful true
you're not getting your standard nine
hours and that's why I feel like I'm
definitely Limited in My Success like
like I think I'm probably close to like
hitting my Peak because like you bet
you're awesome sleeping nine hours a
night yeah I slept nine hours outside I
woke up like I was hit by a truck like
it wasn't enough time no I slept not
enough hours last night I woke up at 4
30. maybe that means you're like in your
successful era totally except it's not
like I like did something productive
towards my career this morning you
reared your child but I did wear my
child that's productive towards
everything that's true towards having it
all
well I think Andy Cohen is like really
as close as it comes to having it all so
the book starts where he's like about to
have the second kid okay so you see him
like life is as a dad of one and then a
dad of Two And what I really like about
the book is like he wakes up with a pit
every day about something he said either
on the radio and something he said the
book starts after New Year's Eve and it
was right after he called Ryan Seacrest
a loser and went on the Bill de Blasio
ran and it was like the Bill de Blasio
thing like he became a New York hero
like people on the street were like
pounding him and then with the Ryan
Seacrest thing he had like such a pit
because Kelly Ripa is like such a good
friend of his and this was Kelly and
Ryan and he didn't realize he called
Ryan Seacrest a loser he just meant the
people that work at ABC are losers got
it and he was just saying that like
coming from like NBC Supremacy no he was
on CNN but like yeah but just like rival
Network yeah and he was drunk like and
it was like he's like who cares like
people leave this show on for five hours
like nobody actually watches but it's
five hours of like me saying stuff right
so I actually really resonated with like
literally every day it's a pit and every
day he says something he gets picked up
yeah and he also he was so it's actually
really interesting where we are in the
book a lot of interesting things happen
things are happening that he's trying to
navigate like Jenny from Salt Lake City
her old Facebook post resurfacing Mary
and her crazy [__] and then not showing
up to the reunion so he basically just
like all he like he doesn't really have
an opinion on anything he just doesn't
want to get like dragged into people's
[__] yeah so he was like he like I think
what he said was like you know we're
doing our best at vetting people and
like then that got picked up and he just
like can't win
um but also what's interesting about
Andy is he literally never leaves the
West Village and when he does he can
never get a cab home like he can never
find a cab he pretty much like once a
week takes a ride from a fan
why doesn't he have Uber he does but
like I guess he's he's always in Midtown
by like Sirius XM where there's like so
much traffic or the West Village where
there's so much traffic he can never
he's always like waiting out
for a ride and like someone will always
pull over and be like Oh my wife is a
fan like a truck driver was like oh my
God my wife so we FaceTime the wife from
the truck and literally took a ride
downtown from this truck driver
that's really sweet but like why the not
have a car yeah I think he's rich like
he could have a car and driver totally
um but she said like summed it like one
day like no like no Uber would pick him
up and there was like no fan in sight
that he was like actually like modeling
his face in the street like so everyone
could see him on display like hoping
that someone would pick it up it's a
really funny book it does get a little
repetitive because it's just like every
day like here's what I did with the kids
Watch What Happens Live and then every
couple of days there's something crazy
that happens but like for sometimes but
I find myself Googling so much because
he was basically saying
it was tough because he's Was preparing
for his daughter to be born so he taped
like a week of shows in one day so it's
10 guests you have to guess who it was I
literally went to Google I was like who
was a guest on the week of April 6 and
there was like 10 people he said there
was somebody so rude to the staff like
he never saw anything like it and then
on the show was like a delight and now
they're banned from Watch What Happens
Live do you who are the names from that
week
um it was confusing because like the
names that he had cited who he said it
wasn't them but like we filmed with this
person weren't on the schedule it was he
made it impossible for someone to figure
out yeah but there's like a lot of
there's a lot of good tea and I haven't
gone to the Meghan Markle thing yet
right so I'm assuming there's more tea
to be had okay you're a good case for it
I can't read it no you would like it
just like a lot of like the balancing
like and he's like I refuse to be like
an involved a non-involved parent like
yeah and he's totally transparent like
he has help he has a baby nurse and he
just has like a nanny for the kids
um but he's really like as involved as
as he could be at his level of success
right and it's really sweet that's nice
okay I'm feeling influenced yeah it's
good no but it's just so light and so
easy like after reading this book for my
book club that was really like genuinely
[__] horrible the things we left in
which we unfinished
um which took me quite literally two
weeks to finish this book after last
time I'm ready like 45 and it's just
like light and easy and and fun and
fresh nice speaking of books I read and
finished the Sally hepbworth book the
new one the soul mate that I'm gonna
choose for my book club we love Sally
Hepworth here and I loved the soulmate I
really did not know like what was going
to be and it pulls you in really quickly
and I really enjoyed my time with it
like just as much as every other book
maybe even more than some others I would
have to like think about them in order
to write them but they're all good the
thing is you pick up a Sally Hepworth
book she's like Ellen Hilda right now
like it's gonna be good it's gonna be
good and that's such a relief like yeah
no it was it was really good so so I'm
choosing it you recommend yeah okay
because like the book club's going
through a drought like we thought this
book Was Gonna Save Us book clubs that's
part of book club like unless you're
following
um
or unless it's something that someone in
the club has already read that ruins it
and then they recommend it to the group
like if you guys are going in blind like
part of book club is flopping I mean the
redheads we know all about that I know
and what's really tough is that like
everyone in our book club is like a
really active reader they read like a
couple books a month so we can't choose
anything like obvious that's charting on
Goodreads because somebody has already
read it same with the redhead
s so hard to be us we make this life
look easy Jax but it's not it's not easy
to be a part of a thriving book club no
it's really not but did I tell you we
came up with a name for our book club
the yellow bellies no the balabusta book
club oh that's good because like
everyone mostly everyone in it is like a
wife actually everyone in it is like a
domesticated Queen and ever and when we
meet up everyone like cooks and like
sets the table and makes it like a real
dinner party and balabusta is what
Yiddish yeah for like you know a nice
homemaking Queen yeah so we're the Bala
Buster book club I like when everyone is
Jewish so they knew what all of us
demand I like that a lot
um because I like it I forget I gave you
one other suggestion it was like booked
and busy or something like that cooked
and booked because we're always cooking
or something that's good no I didn't
give you that but then it sounds like
we're like making drugs
true no I like Bala Buster book club
speaking of drugs this morning I think
it's about not Buster I didn't say
Buster Alabaster balabusta
um speaking of drugs when I was getting
ready this morning I'm watching a new
episode of good guys
um and it was so good I saw what you
posted and I found it a little hurtful I
know well obviously I found a hair fell
towards the toast I thought it hurtful
towards the redheads well I said that
good guys is literally the best podcast
out there but I was just trying to like
hype them up obviously didn't mean like
you know it's number one in the world
like it was obviously just a euphemism I
figured you of all people could read
through my euphemisms yeah I don't know
you said it so emphatically and you
don't really like give away well I was
just like cackling it's really so funny
you're allowed to you're allowed to I'm
allowed to like something
yeah
yeah thanks
um and they just did like a whole top
like section at the beginning talking
about drugs um like experimenting with
drugs and like the first time they've
ever tried and Josh obviously like ended
up becoming a drug addict but they kept
it really like light and funny and Josh
was saying like how he tried MDMA for
the first time and he was like guess
where I was and Ben was like a rave he
was like I was in my apartment
completely alone what yeah
was that like while he was a drug addict
I think it was on the way on the way
well it was actually really interesting
what he said was like I didn't think I
was a drug addict because I would take
drugs and like feel like myself like I
had no insecurities and I was like alive
so he's like it never occurred to me
that I was literally becoming an addict
I just thought it was becoming myself it
was really interesting that is
interesting that's what you get on the
good guys like hilarity but realness
introspection introspection and Josh is
like you know just like a dad and like
really has lived yeah and so and and Ben
is in the process of living so they
really offer a very unique perspective
and so does Josh give Ben advice yeah
well Ben was telling the story on the
podcast of like one of the only times
he's ever done Molly and the first time
he did it he was at like a rave when he
was in college at he was visiting a
friend at the University of Albany Ben
said this yeah okay and somebody gave
him Molly and he was like you know what
sure
and literally 10 minutes later uh it was
like 12 o'clock so it was like perfect
timing 10 minutes after the lights
turned on the party was over you need to
walk home on Molly yeah that's why you
shouldn't do drugs yeah because you just
never know when the party's gonna be
over you never want to turn the lights
on yeah you can't time it no you really
shouldn't do drugs no definitely not
they're so unsafe they're literally
illegal well that too but you just never
you don't know what you're getting so
true it's just all mixed up in these
dark Economic Times like people do
anything for a buck yeah no it's all
crap out there so just be safe you guys
that's the lesson of today's episode
yeah
what else not much else we've got a
second coffee today mine as well I'm not
well I'm not well either because I woke
up early why aren't you well you got and
I know because I'm like a disgusting
slob who doesn't take care of herself
and all she does is like sleep and
wonder why she's tired
got it also stay tuned for tomorrow's
episode because tonight is the night I'm
like really hoping to run into Taylor
Swift
like Taylor was out and about last night
we're going to talk about it she's in
New York
I'm going out to like a hot spot tonight
and I just I feel it I feel like she's
gonna be there
okay
manifested no just like please I've like
so many of my friends in the last few
weeks have like been at the place that
Taylor was at and they text like oh my
God she's here yeah like it's happened
like two or three times when is it my
turn I just feel like she might like
stay in tonight with Maddie no it's
Tuesday but it is gorgeous weather it's
gorgeous weather she's you know in her
Paparazzi era she's gonna hit the town
and the town's gonna head back and so
it's dirty okay and are you gonna be
ready yeah you're not gonna flub oh I
mean I might be like
I might like like stop learning like
stop knowing how to speak English but
I'm going in just like feeling confident
okay do you know what you're wearing no
you should wear the sweater should I
wear merch you should wear the sweater I
think I'll wear toes March so it's like
maybe like she's seen it she's like oh
you're the toast girl
there's no way on God's green diddly
dally I don't know do you think Joey the
toast is literally than a moment podcast
in the world it is but I feel like she
doesn't listen to podcasts she literally
just said that she doesn't even read
articles about herself like yeah but
it's possible like somebody in her group
Johnson was like by the way Tay like
listen to this these girls were talking
about you like it was so funny oh okay
fine yeah I don't think she sits down at
her computer every day and listens but
like maybe she's been sent one of her
Clips I don't know I feel so far removed
from her world I know like there are
other celebrities where it's like I can
there's a
separation like he had no it's possible
that they've like seen it but I just
feel like not she's so like out of our
Out Of Reach yeah that's what it was for
everyone too yeah yeah I was gonna say
out of touch like I can't think of any
podcast that I think like Taylor dabbles
in
maybe like a true crime yeah like
totally
a political in the sense of like pop
culture yes not pop culture not politics
not sports like seriously True Crime not
entertainment True Crime not society and
culture I feel like she probably
listened to a true crime podcast and
then wrote I did it but it just came and
prove it that's my skip on Evermore
that's a very fair assessment
and if we keep talking like this she'll
never listen
so true but we've said such nice things
I mean I would lay my life out on the
line for the girl like the least you
could do is listen to my podcast
[Laughter]
that's true um should we dive in yeah
let's dive in so we can talk about
Taylor well it's already been 20 minutes
like what have we spoken about in the
last 20 minutes but we had that fight at
the top oh that was like we're toxic
four or five minutes then the book talk
book talk I guess I did go on like a
little long about Andy's book you did
yeah that's what we've been talking
about oh but like exciting development
in my life like I post about Andy's book
and he responded thanks oh cool yeah
this is exciting yeah now I have like
open DMS I'm sure he moved me to General
but like still yeah that's exciting
happy for you without further Ado here
are the fast side stories that you need
to know
and today's episode is brought to you by
bowling Branch wake up feeling rested
and refreshed with the softest most
luxurious sheets from Bowling Branch
Bolin branch is the expert in betting
they make the highest quality sheets
with Incredible craftsmanship each sheet
set is slow made for an unmatched
softness with 100 traceable organic
cotton that gets softer with every wash
now I have a lot of friends who listen
to this podcast and like after months
and months and years and years of
talking about bowling Branch they
finally are like hey what's the code I'm
going to listen to you finally and the
way I've seen such a difference in their
character there's so much Kinder because
they're well rested and they said turdy
I should have listened to you a long
time ago ain't that the truth so Jackie
and I love bowling Branch sheets we love
all of their bedding accoutrement we
have lots of different accessories like
throw blankets from them but really
their sheet sets are What Make the World
Go Round so we both have the signature
hem sheet collection from Bowling Branch
it's their best seller they're loved by
millions of sleepers they're buttery to
the touch they're really breathable but
they'll also keep you warm so they're
perfect for year-round sleeping and
they're made with the highest quality
100 organic cotton threads on Earth they
come in 10 versatile colors and all
sizes so that's twin up to California
King they're made without toxins free
from synthetic pesticides formaldehyde
and other harsh chemicals best of all
they're giving you a 30 night risk-free
guarantee with free shipping and Returns
on all U.S orders so sleep better at
night with the bowl and Branch sheet
sets get 15 off your first order when
you use promo code toast at bowl and
branch.com that's bowling Branch
b-o-l-l-a-n-d
branch.com promo code toast exclusions
apply Seaside for details today's
episode is also brought to you by
Squarespace you need a website you start
in a little side hustle a Blog an
e-commerce business check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
so there are many different reasons why
you might be revamping your website
creating a website whether that's
e-commerce you want to sell products you
want to do blogging
Squarespace is everything you need to
get your website up and running but you
don't need like a degree in software
engineering to figure it out it is so
easy you'll look like you have a
professional grade website and it really
works and it was easy as pie so here are
some of the features that are great if
especially if you're an e-commerce
Squarespace is a space to sell anything
they have the tools that you need to get
your business off the ground including
e-commerce templates inventory
management a simple checkout process and
secure payments whatever you sell
squarespace's merchandising features to
make your products look their best
online you can connect your social media
accounts you can get a traffic overview
which is basically seeing how your
visits unique visitors page user
trending over time and the content
ownership so you own all the content
that you put on the Squarespace platform
they just offer a one-click data
portability so it's really easy to do
you can do email campaigns you can
collect donations you can share on
social media they have great tools for
blogging so whatever the reason is for
starting a website check out
squarespace.com toast for a free trial
and when you're ready to launch use
offer code toast to save 10 off your
first purchase of a website or a domain
you're welcome Jackie our first Story
Taylor Swift and Maddie Healy leave in
New York City recording studio together
amid dating rumors another one like
they're dating yeah this one I I still
will you're allow rumors what just
because like
no I guess you're right you're right
you're right sorry tailored and the 1975
from Taylor tailored and the front man
were spotted leading Electric Lady
recording studio together in NYC Monday
night amid the rumors that they're
dating she kept her look casual and an
oversized in my you sweatshirt and skirt
while Maddie looked Dapper and all Black
Ensemble so they're leaving this
recording studio so you think oh are
they recording together that was my
initial thought as well but then other
celebs were at that studio that night I
think there was a party yeah I think
Taylor threw the party you think she
threw the party that's what I had read
that's what I had read it was like
Taylor's party
Kendrick Lamar was there uh Florence and
the Machine no machine just Florence
shove the machine at home
um so it was like uh so they definitely
weren't recording right because the
machine wasn't there unless it's a
a quad
but there was a quartet there was like a
bunch of other people there too okay um
so yeah when I first saw it I was like
oh my God not this whole thing being
like a lead up for a song but no it was
a party they left together in the same
car and there were two takeaways for me
from this very very brief you know video
of them walking out of the
the studio to their car it was literally
three seconds the first was fans were
quick to point out on Twitter which I
appreciated that all the foundation on
Taylor Swift's nose had run off had
rubbed off like almost like she'd been
making out and like you know when you
like bump noses with someone like she
has no Foundation left on her nose or
yeah probably or she's a runny nose it's
allergy season [__] the pollen this year
is yes like Peak pollen for me okay
that's [__] okay but 350. yeah but I
also feel like hear me out this is like
something Taylor strucker and I were
talking about like stealth wealth
um I feel like allergies is like a
problem that rich people like don't
have because like they go from there
like perfectly ventilated cars she
walked three seconds on the street into
like her perfectly ventilated Studio you
know yes but the pun comes forever I
know I know but do you feel like they
also have like special drugs
can't be having like a post nasal drip
when she's on time I thought you were
gonna say special drugs not because they
could spend all their time inside and
then cars like
other people could do that too if uh if
they wanted to if they wanted to and and
the allergies were really bothering them
like don't leave your house but because
they might have special drugs yeah
because Taylor really can't be dealing
with like a runny nose post nasal drip
when she's trying to sing that like
affects your voice yeah so she probably
has that then my other takeaway but I do
think it was the making out the reason
why all the makeup on her nose had
rubbed off probably that's like so like
remember that picture of like Kylie and
Jaden Smith leaving the movie theater
when they were 11 years old and she had
no Foundation left and he had foundation
on his like mouth nose and lips yeah
that's what it reminds me of and then my
second takeaway it's like just so funny
how like you know people become better
looking when you see them through a
different lens like I don't really find
Matty Healy like to be all that cute is
that my type I don't know like seeing
him walk out with Taylor like I was like
oh he's hot like I see it now you know
yeah
I don't I still not for me but like for
her they're a nice looking couple
there's also something about the why at
the end of his name that like makes him
cute do you agree in the Maddie or the
Healy oh such a good question Maddie
like no I said the opposite oh no I'm
sorry I grew up watching awkward do you
remember that show yeah and the way I
was absolutely in love with Maddie like
oh my God I would have taken a bullet
for him and like I just wanted him and
Jenna even though Jenna was worst to be
together and he was like you know every
High School fantasy
the fact that his name was Maddie like
made him even cuter because he was like
hopping like Maddie's a cute name but
this guy's 34. no I like um uh because I
like it like is he a grandpa and they're
gonna call him Maddie
that's like adorable that is fine like
not a grandpa yet but like an old you
know there's definitely gonna be like a
weird transition between now and Grandpa
Hood where it might not fit yeah but I
like it because you like it yeah
that's all you had to say yeah so he's
like he's becoming cuter to me like
that's what Taylor's doing I don't need
him to become cuter for me like I'm
really happy for her selection but this
doesn't sound mean that I need to become
like a fan of his and listen to his
music and like get it but we were
listening to The 1975 before we started
filming today we made it into the
pre-show playlist what did you think
it sounded like exactly what I thought
it would sound like it sounded exactly
as how I just sang it for you and just
based on like what there was a moment a
few months ago like a literal week where
everyone's obsessed with the 1975. yeah
because there had been a clip of him
that went viral singing The Bridge of
so I got it found it just gotta keep it
don't [__] it you Muppet that's why
whatever reason and some of those clips
made their way to Reels to Reels I guess
and you had spoken about him so I was
familiar and so it all is in line with
what I thought about him got it I just
thought he was looking cute last night
that's all I was trying to say I'm happy
that you think that yeah because she's
your girl so maybe Taylor should watch
her back if I run into her tonight oh
plot twist no I'm happy that you are
half like you
endorses choice for her I don't know why
I just feel like Matty Healy like pretty
Taylor like is a very anti-social person
I feel like he's probably really tired
from like going all these parties I mean
do you see his face in all these
pictures it looks like a little kid like
beating Paparazzi and thinking no stop
the flash maybe he has a toxic
relationship with the paparazzi yeah no
I think he's trying to be annoying yeah
it was a two-second walk yeah
but
every single picture is like wear
sunglasses yeah Taylor kept casual and
NYU crew neck I love her outfit I do it
just doesn't give me I threw a party
outfit no it doesn't it doesn't give
Hostess Vibes I don't think it was a
party and I don't think she threw it
well okay but what's been reported is
that it is a party and she threw it I'm
questioning everything as you should as
you should I I think it was something
else industry things that we'll never
understand oh that's another thing from
Andy's book he was like
I did a red carpet and I saw like that
went from page six who's like always
misconstring what I say and then he was
like see uh The Music Man openings
whatever like Googled I tried to find
who his like arch nemesis is at page
checks but I couldn't find what he was
talking about so many things like I went
to Google from his book and I was left
at a dead end but he has like a nemesis
who works there and I really want to
know who it is I'm sure if we just read
stories about him and we could figure it
out I wonder if it's the same as my
Nemesis or mine or should I say Nemesis
we have different demon Seasons we do
have different embassies at page six I
won't say your name because the last
time I did she like littered her pants
she like sent me a nasty [__] email
she was like gonna write this article so
I just like posted the email on my
Instagram that's how you do like power
mode being like this wench wants
to know my thoughts here are my thoughts
yeah and she was like oh she literally
like crapped her pants and I put her
name like you literally work in media
calm down
so I think that's just like a lesson to
all journalists like don't come for me
I'll snap your neck yeah
are you ready for our next story yeah
yes
what
I'll tell you later oh okay Kim
Kardashian is shopping for a home in Tom
Brady's Community page six is saying
that the pair are quote friendly yeah I
don't know why everyone like started
crapping their pants like these two are
so nice there's a lot of pants crapping
happening yeah
um today's episode is sponsored by
Cottonelle literally I agree they're not
dating yeah
Kim and Tom have it's not even a couple
named Kim and Tom what are they going to
be called calm
Tim wait can't wait wait Tim and Kim
wait Tom oh sorry I'm telling you yeah
that's all right no it doesn't roll off
the tip of the tongue they've struck a
friendship up as she looks to buy a
vacation home in his exclusive Bahamian
neighborhood they make it seem like
these two are dating and she's buying a
house down the street from him because
she's so obsessed with him meanwhile
like she's just trying to look for a
vacation house and he happens and he has
like a rich community that he knows
about yeah so she caught him like they
said that she called him up to ask him
for his advice on the community yeah Kim
likes that Bahamas place when she
stopped remember when she was Paparazzi
for the first time with Pete Davidson
wearing jeans in the Bahamas and then
getting off that little seaplane yeah
she was also going to that community in
the Bahamas yeah she's there all the
time also the other um I think like
Kendall's there all the time yeah like
it's just a fun place for celebrities to
go and I guess at a certain point it
makes sense to get a house there if
you're going all the time yeah so that's
what she's doing she's not dating Tom
Brady I didn't think for a second that
she was like and if they were like that
one actually be like a letdown I don't
think that's good like a good next step
for either of them no it's like please
if they were actually dating like you
know I'd be so here for it but it's at
one it's too good to be true it's too
obvious it's not happening no it's not
not it's not happening no and I had read
that Tom Brady like had a girlfriend
like a model or something but that was a
while ago that was a while ago it's hard
to keep up with these singles
yeah I never thought that they were
dating so this didn't get my hopes up or
down no but people are have been very
quick to be like run don't
run down what run don't beat it with him
with her like why the fans aren't here
for it oh really why what's the fans
reasoning I mean I could find out I just
like didn't give it the toxic clicks no
you shouldn't I think of the toxicity
quick clicks like a couple losers posted
up some tweets that's an article you
know what I mean no it's so interesting
that what makes news these days like
somebody like there's a couple people in
your Instagram comments all upset fan
slam Kim Kardashian and slam literally
that's what it this is the headline fans
rip Kim Kardashian and Tom Brady
friendship quote run Tom why and it was
they flooded page six's Instagram
comments so they're reporting on their
own comment section where random [__]
people wrote run Tom run and he needs to
steer clear of her that's not new no it
ain't who cares with some smelly Joe in
Idaho things a third comment was even
more succinct with a one-word comment
quote gross
I can't believe that that gets written
up yeah
however not everyone was quite so
negative one person argued now that
would be an interesting relationship oh
so the point of this is that an argument
so the point of this article is to say
people have conflicting opinions no yeah
but instead they're ripping slamming
another person said I would love to see
this happen why do I care no it's really
a pointless article that's why you just
gotta read headlines these days like
yeah no that's why that's why I didn't
click it then I'm glad I didn't but I'm
glad we clicked it now and got to the
bottom of it it's just so important to
be like an astute
consumer of pop culture like there's so
much fraudulence out there I feel like I
have a really good bar now like for what
I believe what I don't believe like what
what headlines I could literally skip
past knowing they're not true yeah but
you got to be very
on alert yeah you've got to get dressed
and stay on alert
yeah which is exactly what I'm doing
tonight and if you listen to all
episodes of the toast you would
understand that reference but if you
skip some days you're lost I wonder why
like someone might skip a day of the
time as a toaster on my free time like
sometimes you just don't have it depends
on your day and it's like you could work
on catching up but you might it might
take too long like it just depends on
your schedule yeah I think that's also
why like you know our numbers do dip a
little bit in the summer like people
actually have [__] to do yeah I respect
that and I think like they're on
vacation you don't need to listen to a
podcast all the time like when you're
commuting you need it yeah of course
it's just the monotony of life it makes
sense to me yeah are you ready for our
next story yeah while we're like zooming
through today now are we
I guess not I don't know I guess time
flies when you're having a great time
with your sister time flies when you're
wearing a beautiful cardigan you would
know I wouldn't
I'm not wearing a cardigan so you would
know
Miss
[Music]
you know for girls talking about moving
on you're certainly not
you're just so attached to this cardigan
I don't think I should take it
okay
okay and now I've worn it once right
right no honestly like once something
leaves my house it's your problem now
I'm not bringing it back it feels like a
studio problem honestly we should get it
for him to hang it up literally the
cardigan that launched a thousand ships
yeah sound off in the comments do you
like the cardigan team cardigan team
nardigan love that no our next story is
crazy news because Vanderpump Rules
dropped a clip from the new episode oh
my God I missed it that airs tomorrow
night the way like my whole week has
been leading up like I know I literally
was gonna go out to dinner Wednesday
night but then I was like then I won't
be able to watch Vanderpump Rules on
time no and um because I've been like
traveling so much these last few weeks
we haven't done a recap so like
Thursday's episode like you guys ain't
[__] ready caught up in your personal
life right like no I actually have one
more I'm I'm gonna watch I I haven't
watched last week's episode but I want
to watch it back to back tomorrow okay I
don't want to sit down at eight watch
from eight to nine the old episode nine
ten the new episode 10 to 10 30 watch
Romans live and Ariana's on watching
Evans live and then
toast toast so it's all fresh in my mind
okay well they dropped a clip you know
they're one minute uh so smart not even
a trailer like here's a minute of the
show where Ariana sits down with Katie
and Sheena and explains like what she
learned when how she learned it so she
said that Raquel had sex with Sandoval
in her car while Ariana was reeling from
her dog's death
so people has the exclusive clip where
Ariana reveals to friends Katie and
Sheena how she found out about Tom
cheating on her she said quote I went to
Tom with I went with Tom to Tom Tom
because he had that party thing I found
a screen recording of them on FaceTime
it was literally from the night before
he was at Tom Schwartz's Katie was like
he was at she was doing that at
Schwartz's from there Ariana explains
that she confronted Raquel directly to
get answers she said I called Raquel and
I started like making her like [__]
tell me what the [__] when did this
start she said right after the girls
trip I'm like you mean right after
Charlotte died because she left the
garage a flashback then shows uh Ariana
leaving the girls trip back in her
conversation with Katie and Sheena
Ariana explains what Raquel told her she
said they kissed well later that night
when we were out here I pressed Tom and
he said well they actually [__] in her
car that night and he didn't have a key
to get in so he had to ring the doorbell
and I had to let him in
oh my God I mean
like this is really the moment we've
been waiting for and honestly I would
we'll say Bravo like did not do a bad
job like they didn't drag anything out
and we really are getting everything
like everyone's like fully bleeding out
for this so I'm very grateful
um but I still even with this like the
timeline is so confusing to me um it's
so confusing because I think and I mean
short said this on his disastrous Watch
What Happens Live appearance but it made
a little bit of sense that like their
Affair wasn't linear it's not like they
like had an emotional affair right and
then they kissed and then they like
fought their feelings and then they had
sex and then they you know it didn't
like evolve like a normal relationship I
think from what I understand like they
had sex over the summer like kind of
out of nowhere and I don't think then
from there they started a full-bone
affair like I think they were on ice for
a little bit and then more so in the
fall did they like get into it that's
what I think okay so not linear no not
linear that does make sense I just can't
and you know what's so crazy is like I
guess Tom had already had all of these
Tom and the most extra performances
scheduled it's a travesty and he had
already had all these like shows booked
and tickets sold and you know how much
money he spends like paying these people
to hang out with him a thousand dollars
a day so
um he like has to still do these shows
even though he's become like the most
hated man in America and the footage I
have seen it's tragic and if I didn't
hate him so much I would feel sorry for
him by the way I was gonna say it's to
the they're so pathetic that I actually
like watch them and I actually feel like
a semblance of sadness for him like
that's how bad they are but I want to
know you know before this happened like
there were people buying tickets to this
show and those people need to be held
accountable
that's you know I want to talk about
that yeah people who actually like liked
Tom Sandoval enough to buy tickets and
want to see him cover songs that he
didn't write with arguably one of the
worst voices I've ever heard in my life
like there were people who were looking
forward to that and I hate to yuck
someone's yums but I want to know I want
to get into the mind of that person no I
I totally agree they need to speak for
themselves to me that's more interesting
that is really interesting watching him
be on tour right now is so painful to
watch and a part of me is like how is he
just going out there every night like
how had he not canceled the shows but
like
he it's income no it's income and also
tickets are sold like you have to
understand we're not dealing with like a
normal functioning human being we're
dealing with like a unbelievable
narcissist like with actual like
problems like it's not shocking team
that he's going out there and like
giving the same energy like he doesn't
look even remotely ashamed which is even
more shameful what's worse this week he
like changed up the lyrics Stacy can't
you see Raquel's not the girl for me
whatever because his mom Schwartz's mom
like the foreskin of all people would go
to the show and be like shorts his mom
and he would hold up a picture there
were people who were eating that up and
I think that's like a really big
conversation worth having like who I
agree I totally agree Show Yourself show
yourselves and unburden yourselves yeah
yeah like if anything now I think
tickets are more interesting
like I would buy a ticket now before I
bought a ticket then a comedy and a
tragedy it's a Shakespearean experience
she experienced like it's
it's otherworldly I can't even explain
it it's out of body it's like you know
what it feels wrong to witness it's like
a car wreck I yes the more we talk about
it like I kind of want to go
just so I can like experience like I but
like what do you think about the people
who are going and like holding signs and
like heckling him
that's mean like actually like it's just
like unnecessary it's nicer to not go
and it's a bad use of your time yeah
like I would only go just I need to
witness it yeah no I will have a silent
Observer I wouldn't bring a sign or a
Heckle or anything no it would just like
politely clap yeah it would only just be
to like see the environment but if
you're going to a show that you spend
money on to like hold a sign that he's a
worm or whatever like I I there are more
fun ways to spend yourself oh and we
also didn't talk about how we got a
trailer for The Reunion
last week yeah it was everyone was you
know taking away poo poo head
which was moronic but when he called him
a worm with a mustache that was funny
um and there's a few different setups
because obviously Raquel and Sheena
can't be in the same room which is kind
of annoying because it looks like we
spent a lot of time with Sheena
yeah like sheena's just gonna have to
take a back seat and then I then Andy
had said there is like a one-on-one with
Tom and Ariana Tom Ariana and Raquel
Raquel and Tom do they talk about
anything else that happened this season
I don't know I hope not like I know
actually I would like a special time
carved out for Satchel
agree Katie was on my shopping list week
and she said her and such are not
together but he's doing very well that's
all you could ask I just hope for you
know a happy satch happy satch greater
than unhappy one the other thing I was
going to say about Tom's show was like
the fact that he's trying to get in on
the moment of scandival by like changing
the lyrics and like throwing Raquel
under the bus but all but also like
admitting like oh she's my girl and but
I can also like his mom more no but then
also like screaming at TMZ that like
Raquel is in a mental health facility
like everybody needs to back off like
she's literally struggling and then
going on stage and making fun Raquel's
not the girl for me like you're
literally part of the problem dude no
but like I think you know it makes sense
both ways like he's not with Raquel so
he's like making a joke about it or it's
like Raquel is the love of his life but
still Schwartz's mom you know right but
I do think him and Raquel are together I
think so too but it's just such an act
of desperation oh yeah cash in on like
your
Fall From Grace yeah if you can even
call it Grace where he was before yeah
this whole Saga just really taught me
like trust your instincts like I've been
a good judge of character I knew I knew
he was a problem
no this whole Saga has taught me like
you don't know anything about anyone
that you think that you've done that's
true that you think that you know you
think you know them you think that they
know that you know but they know that
you know and people are capable of crazy
things are you wearing a sugar lips
today tank top it looks like a sugar
lips it's not it does look like a sugar
lips it's hatch maternity oh it
throwback to sugar lips when we would
like layer those color tank tops like
but it's giving sugar lips oh my God I
could not breathe in a sugar lips right
well it has like the ribbed yes it does
it literally looks like a sugar lips it
does it's really cozy should we bring
sugar lips back I can't postpartum
postpartum yeah yeah it's like a
compression thing yeah I used to like
wear it instead of a bra
well those were the days yeah imagine me
it is sugar lips without a bra right now
and be in the hospital be a different
kind of show it would
are you ready for our next story if this
is not brought to you by sugar lips no
it's brought to you by kiwico kiwiko
kiwiko believes that every kid is
naturally creative and curious and that
Hands-On experiences build creative
confidence and problem-solving skills
that can change the world so kiwico
delivers seriously fun learning for kids
of all ages
excuse me I sneezed on it it's true
whether it's about science or sensory
play games geography every crate
designed by their team of experts
inspires excitement curiosity and
moments of Discovery so kiwico is fun
learning they are delivering fun
Hands-On projects that inspire a
lifelong love of learning so their
projects spark creative confidence for
ongoing tinkering and expert
experimentation sure you can buy a robot
but isn't it way more fun to build your
own I love cubico because like one thing
I've learned about about being an aunt I
was going to say a nurse about being an
aunt is like there's a lot of time in
the day yeah and kids you know you buy
them a new shiny toy and it's seven
minutes of your life like there's
another couple of hours before they go
to bed and kiwico is like delivering
these projects that take a lot of time
so it's like you're keeping them busy
but it's also learning and it's
developing and engaging and it really is
like a fabulous thing to have just
delivered to your house yes and the
crate is legit like it's a big delivery
which is also exciting a crate kids love
a crate they do and after they do the
project they play with the crate
so their crates are fun and stress fees
free so you can enjoy quality time
tackling projects together they're
designed by experts a team of Educators
makers engineers and Rocket scientists
who brainstorm hundreds of ideas to
create the most exciting age-appropriate
and educational projects they're tested
and approved by kids
it's hard to find creative ways to keep
the kids in your life busy Challenge and
off their screens so no crate from
kiwico's Innovation Factory leads
without approval from their toughest
critic the kids redefine learning with
play explore Hands-On projects that
build creative confidence with kiwico
get 50 off your first month plus free
shipping on any crate that's kiwico.com
toast that's 50 off your first month at
k-i-w-i-c-o.com slash toast kiwico kid
tested toast approved it's also just
like a great gift for the mom in your
life you know if you're an aunt or you
have you know a friend who's a mom it's
really helpful today's episode is also
brought to you by seed seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic is a plant-based Prebiotic and
probiotic with 24 strain that have been
clinically or scientifically studied for
its benefits it's free from 14 classes
of allergens defined by the efsa and
more including sugar-free vegan soy-free
Sesame free gluten-free peanut free ampa
free dairy free shellfish free corn free
there's no binders there's no
preservatives
you take two capsules once a day on an
empty stomach this could be the first
thing in the morning 30 minutes before
your first meal or two hours after your
last meal it's engineered to survive
your external and internal environments
so their capsule and capsule via cap
safeguards viability through digestion
for delivery of an average of 100 of our
probiotics starting dose to your colon a
lot of times you know you'll take a
probiotic and it won't even make its way
down your digestive tract but not with
sea roads on the way down 16 out of
their 24 strains are specifically geared
towards digestive health so if digestive
health is one of your goals why don't
you check out seed
um people are taking a probiotic for
Digestive Health so makes sense but
there's also a lot of other benefits
like skin Health their daily symbiotic
has four specific probiotic strains and
has been shown to promote healthy skin
and reinforce gut skin access so in
layman's terms what can seed do for you
all right you want to make big soft
duties
seed that's it and I know they don't let
us say that but between us digestive
skin big soft duties
so avoid gutmania and head to the
trusted source for symbiotics start a
new healthy habit today visit seed.com
toast and use code toast to redeem 25
off your first month of seeds ds01 daily
symbiotic that's seed.com toast and use
code toast
t-o-a-s-t seed.com toast thank you
Claudia you're welcome our next story
real housewives ultimate girls trip Real
Housewives of New York legacy cast has
been officially revealed after behind
the scenes tumult so real house eyes of
New York City Legacy has now turned into
a real housewives ultimate girls trip of
Real Housewives New York Legacy and the
cast is Ramona Singer Dorinda medley
Luanne de lesseps Sonia Morgan Kelly Ben
Simone and Kristen takeman Sonia Morgan
was not at the upfronts where they
announced this yesterday
interesting so I feel like she has stuff
going on yeah but like a lot of the
comments I actually thought she wasn't
in it until you just read right now all
the comments were like what about Sonia
so maybe she was just booked but maybe
she was booked maybe she couldn't make
it the ladies will jet off to saline
beach in Saint Barts and stay at the
same home as the wow cast in season five
did that's you know
no that was Turks and Caicos really yeah
no scary Island Disney Parts was in um
the pirate
Saint Barts was the pirate oh maybe
that's okay
is be cool don't be uncool yeah okay
wasn't it be cool about the pirate no
that was about the man that woke up in
in Heather's bed okay okay
is Turks and Caicos okay be cool don't
be all uncool it's Turks it's Turks and
Caicos
St Barts is pirate
okay but St Parts is also scary Island
not to my knowledge with Aviva season
five
Aviva season five yeah even would be
season five
I'm just confused now
there's so many trips I know but they
definitely meant to say Barts more than
once but Saint Gary Island Aviva wasn't
on scary Island that's why oh wait
that's your two are white trash quite
frankly yes that's not the same Parts no
I don't know where that is but that's
not scary Island because scary island is
Kelly which is why Kelly's back by the
way they're recreating scary Island
that's why Kelly's here got it but no
Bethany so it's not really scary oh well
in Andy's book
in in the point in time where he's
writing he has the idea to split up Roni
to Legacy and OG and he sends Bethany a
text and is like once the announcement
came out in variety a few weeks later
once they had come up with this idea he
sent it to Bethany was like I know
you're over Housewives but like the door
is always open if you want to come and
she basically was like make me an offer
like if the money's right of course I'll
do it
um and then the next day she made a tick
tock saying that this announcement is
boring and it's going to be dumb and
Andy was like okay weird that's so
Bethany yeah but she still would do it
she said she would but I guess since
she's not on it they didn't offer her
enough money yeah and honestly
on all of this kept getting stalled
because of money so we wound up with not
even a whole show but a ultimate girls
trip because I don't think people could
agree on money
it's just like a lot of new titles and
language to give us a show that we had
10 years ago no and you know what I
actually don't think it's a terrible
idea I think it's probably better than
like a reboot
of you know having two Real Housewives
of New York shows The Real Housewives of
New York knew cast like that looks
horrible like way much a trailer there
wasn't even a trailer it was just like
pictures of them on a rooftop like it
wasn't and like with a voice overlay in
this town yeah yeah there wasn't any
footage from the actual season it just
like I have the worst vibes from it like
I don't think it's gonna be good I
actually like this idea The Real
Housewives ultimate girls trips are
actually performing really well people
really seem to be enjoying them on
peacock so I don't think this is a bad
idea I think they got a really great
group I mean what's more random than
[__] Kristen takeman but whatever I
guess they needed like a sixth yeah I
don't know how I feel about this because
it's like this group of women are just
like
unhinged and they're on vacation for
like a one season only show like it's
gonna be bananas in an incoherent way
yeah well that's what that was where we
got completely sway like where just
everyone's just like blackout drunk and
spewing nonsense and it's like what the
[__] am I watching that's really what
the place we got to with Roni was I was
like this will be even worse because
it's not like they have to like then go
home no it's like a one-time only thing
these women are especially like a lot of
them during the like they really want to
be back in the fold a lot of them
definitely have some sort of alcoholism
so it will be like a hodgepodge but I do
think conceptually it's better than a
reboot yeah but I just find myself when
I'm watching and this always happens
more so on vacation because everybody
lets loose on me yeah and like lay
people as well then I'm just like why am
I this there's no thread of rationale
here I will say like a positive of this
is that this group of friends the group
of women like are actually friends like
I know Luanne and Kelly Ben Simone if I
kept in touch like they're really really
tight
durinda Ramona and Sonia Ramona and
Dorinda so like there is history there
and it's not like a bunch of random
women thrown in the history will make it
a little more cohesive I just do hope
honestly like they taper the alcohol a
little bit of course like when people
get drunk that's when it gets
interesting but they got to a point
where it was incoherent and it wasn't
even fun because the next morning nobody
remembered nobody even cared it's like
we were all drunk whatever so there's no
thread of a storyline because there's no
progress just like P like chaos chaos so
I hope they taper it a little bit you
know Ramona's like very pulled back
these days so I do think she won't be
like the crazy Ramona we think she is
like she's very much in her business
woman era like she's a popular
as much as Ramona's always been the
[__] starter she was never the drunkest
she no like you know her storyline
actually always made it from beginning
to end except she was always just like
saying something crazy apologizing yeah
stop start stop no it's really like to
Brenda and Sonia yeah but where's Luanne
these days in terms of her sobriety yeah
I don't know she's like crushing it
doing her tour that like I feel like
she's probably not drinking yeah I have
no idea though I have no idea she came
out with froze fake Rose or whatever oh
right that was on the show yeah but she
still promotes it a lot it's not fake
Rose it's um it's just non-alcoholic
course because froze is frozen rose
yeah yeah which is disgusting are you
ready for our fifth and final story yeah
because it's some podcasting news okay
and some Royal news Okay Sarah Ferguson
The Duchess of York reviews
reveals her new gig which is spilling
the tea Sarah Ferguson will be spilling
the tea on a new podcast on Monday the
Duchess of York announced the launch of
a new weekly podcast called T talks with
the duchess and Sarah I hate the word
tea in terms of like gossip agree but
she's a Brit I get it I get it it works
better is acceptable here
um Fergie is co-hosting the show with
entrepreneur Sarah Thompson and the
friends say they won't shy away from any
subject she said on Instagram it's about
time we spilled the tea our brand new
podcast t-talks which with the duchess
and Sarah that's confusing it sounds
like herself and herself right The
Duchess and her friend Sarah but it's
like Sarah
uh it's out next week streaming on all
platforms so I just obviously like this
is interesting yeah like podcasting
infiltrating the Royal realm is short of
Royal yeah but like do you think the
palace will be have to listen to every
episode does she behave these days I
don't know she's in which right because
her kids are very much in right her kids
are Beatrice and eugenino yes but I
think she wasn't she just got snubbed
recently but up and at like maybe at the
car Nation I don't know if she was where
she like could or should have been
um but before that she was like in and
she had like all these really nice
tributes with about the queen oh that's
sweet and I think in in recent years
like she's made a mess so I feel like
maybe the palace is like you can do your
own thing but that means that she won't
be talking about anything actually
interesting if she wants to remain in
the good graces right but like you were
the one saying that Charles is very much
in favor of like a trimmed down smaller
core royal family and quite literally
she's not a part of it she's divorce
which is like you know a sin I guess
um and she's also like associated with
Andrew so like really I don't think the
royal family like needs her like she can
go on the podcast and say whatever the
[__] she wants you know but that just
causes trouble for the family I don't
think she's trying to cause trouble no I
don't think she's a monitor I don't know
how you have a podcast as a railing you
don't cause trouble Meghan Markle didn't
really cause trouble that's why it was
boring
that's why I wouldn't consider her
podcast like a major success it was
boring as [__] okay but I'm like you
could say podcast like the realm of
media having a media program so for them
it was like podcast documentary book
other sit down yeah um Oprah
so I think it's a little
odd to
have a royal podcast Royal adjacent
podcast have the Royals ever like the
core like William and everyone have they
ever done any like they do interviews
all the time for like the BBC and [__]
have they done a podcast like Kate did a
podcast once it was like mothering okay
yeah it was not tea right right Duchess
right damn yeah I was just wondering if
that's like a space for foray into also
this is pertinent one of the husbands so
one of the one of like William and
Harry's cousins is a girl who's married
to a man who's a former rugby player and
he has a podcast a successful podcast I
think it's like sports rugby stuff so
there is a royal podcast good to know
yeah no because like podcasting is now a
really it's like a reputable but if like
The Duchess was like I'm doing a true
crime podcast I wouldn't feel like weird
about it they're calling it tea and
saying we're gonna spill the tea like
you make a better [__] spell it's
giving clickbait then you better spill
the tea but then you're out I'm sorry
like it's a catch-22 you can't win I
know I'm like I kind of want the best
for her no me too and she's also
I really I wish her well yeah so I hope
her podcast is boring so she keeps
getting invited to things agreed because
her kids are like really in there yeah
Eugenie and Beatrice I think they're
really close with William and Harry and
yeah and they're major yeah even though
they're like Irrelevant in terms of like
the succession
they're like major social like Queens
yeah and they get invited to everything
and they married well yeah they behave
yeah they do
nice yeah so welcome to the podcasting
realm Sarah and Sarah they said they'll
be having candid conversations as they
spell the tea on the roller coaster of
life now that we're done with the
stories I'm so hungry I have to pee so
badly because I've just consumed so many
beverages like yesterday we were talking
at the end of the show about lunch yeah
and you ended up having to go get your
haircut so like I was on my own for
lunch and I went to my everyday lunch
place and I got the same thing every day
they have this like really good like
garlic butter herb chicken it's a
grilled chicken with like a little
garlic on top it's so good and juicy and
they didn't have it yesterday and so I
was like up there like with my dick in
my hand they were like what chicken and
they were like put your dick away yeah
this is a you know this is a Wendy's and
they were like well you can take the
grilled chicken from like the salad bar
it was like cold and Cubed it was like
it was like I don't want everyone to
like feel bad for me like it was like
literally the worst lunch ever like I
was so upset why didn't you get salmon
just like not my salmon era you know you
have to really be in the mood for salmon
and I'm having salmon for dinner because
I know the menu of the place I'm going
um no but why didn't you get salmon
yesterday
cause like I just wasn't in the mood
like for fish like why I have to have
fish now
yeah
it was just like I'm like I'm really I'm
hoping they have it today
otherwise what there will be a riot
breaking up my lunch I'm trying to fight
it I could go down every night but I'd
be lying if I said I could live and
breathe with out the chicken be a lot of
lonely there'd be a lot of hungry
there'd be a lot of salmon wishing and
praying that you would hold me I would
do most anything baby if only you would
come back to me let's talk about Rascal
Flatts let's because we never got their
legacy tour because of covid thanks Dr
fauci actually saw one of the members uh
Jay Demarcus at the acms he looked
really good he is a very good member
yeah he's not the one who got the DUI
right that was the other backup man
Rascal himself no not not Gary who
follows me on Tick Tock no but they owe
us a farewell tour like I didn't forget
about it just like I didn't forget about
Kelly's residency right and I'm owed we
were going to follow them around the
country and see we were let me ask you a
question when we did we saw them once uh
together in Dallas remember we spent
Memorial Day weekend at your
mother-in-law's which was really a
fabulous trip
um and we saw Rascal Flatts at this
gorgeous Amphitheater did they play Riot
I would I think not because that's like
one of like my favorite Rascal Flatts
songs I don't think that they did play
Riot
what are your favorite Rascal Flatts
songs
it's so hard to say because there's so
many I mean here's to you is one of our
favorites yeah
oh my God I like I feel so put on the
spot whom is Mayberry sitting on a porch
drinking ice cold Cherry Coke like if I
did like if I look
insane means and I could like throw
myself a birthday party like I would
literally like I would how much you
think it would be maybe I should start
saying I don't know but that's like um
Bobby Bones and Caitlyn's wedding yeah
they just got whoever they wanted
because like Rascal Flatts performed
yeah like I'm vomiting I know
I saw them at the acms by the way I
interviewed them I saw their photo at
the ACs so it's kind of the same pretty
much no like literally there's a video
on her Instagram of Rascal himself
singing to her and like there's so many
great Law School songs love songs too
yeah love who you love with no that you
have also Here Comes Goodbye if I want
to jump off a bridge there's also a golf
tournament every year that's like for
like Rich famous people that every year
Rascal Flatts performs I always see like
a couple of like rich people I know like
posting like on their close friend
stories from it that's disgusting that
they would keep like and not invite me
and now no now I don't know that it
hasn't happened in a while since coven
and I don't know if like the next time
it happens or will Rascal Flatts perform
if they do I'm like literally if you're
rich and know what I'm talking about
like somebody invite me okay same yeah
yeah Ben golf oh my God please please I
don't know what it is it's like in
California and it's like all the rich
people I know always go there's always
celebs but it's like low-key nobody like
ever posts like it's always on close
friends
interesting I would like to be invited
hmm all right let's get some lunch okay
let's get some lunch but Rascals we
didn't forget I just I'm glad that you
brought that up because you still owe us
a farewell tour if you're going to take
away the sweet sweet music that you make
thank you yeah thank you thank you so
much
I'm hungry bye love you bye